Microsoft has dug a little deeper into
their mysterious hololens details bag
and brought back a few more tickets
about the fancy augmented reality
headset as reported by the verge
Microsoft's Bruce Harris explained that
the hololens has 5.5 hours of battery
life but this will depend on your usage
under what Harris called heavy load
battery life will be closer to 2.5 hours
he added that they do expect this
battery life to improve over time and
addressed concerns over the hololens is
field-of-view
Harris explained that using hololens
will be similar to looking at a 15 inch
monitor that's two feet away from you
it will also be possible to link
hololens headsets together so that
multiple people can observe the same
object at the same time through the
devices Internet connectivity Steph kits
are due out later this year and they'll
be priced at a whopping three grand no
word yet on what the commercial version
will cost or when else regular Joe's
will be able to pick one up let me know
if you're excited to try out the
hololens and why or why not for all the
latest news on a RvR and everything else
be sure to head to GameSpot calm